one of the oldest civilizations in the
world is having the biggest protest in
human history and instead CNN is showing
wall to wall or as they call it gavel to
gavel that's what ashleigh banfield said
coverage of the George Zimmerman trial
now I'm not diminishing the importance
of the George Zimmerman trial it is very
important there are all kinds of racial
issues we still have to deal with this
country but showing any trial just hours
of trial minutia is just pure pure
drivel especially when important things
are going on should I just get off my
thing with CNN see I have a thing where
I want them to be good because Fox is
awful on ray MSNBC is awful the other
way so I want and that's why I love
working here at the Young Turk because
we're doing that online but I still want
there to be yeah I want there to be
someone giving us actual news am I just
a crazy dreamer no I think CNN is sadly
pandering to the masses in the sense of
what we were just discussing I don't
think America knows what to think about
Egypt I think they're a little scared
and don't really know what to think or
say or do about it so it's so much
easier to you just zone out to the
Zimmerman's Wow and it's it's
disappointing it's really disappointed
shouldn't CNN be the one that's showing
it to us so that weird and [ __ ] I mean
look I'm gonna say something that's not
gonna go over well it's gonna go for
like a fart in church to be honest but
it's below that way the truth is I'm you
know I say it like I mean it um I don't
think Americans first of all names are
so much harder to pronounce can I just
say you know um it's sad that we don't
care as much as that we're so obsessed
with these trials i mean oj simpson
Casey Anthony Jodi arias Amanda Knox you
know now this is the new George
Zimmerman we're fixated on these on
these trials and it's happening on our
own Shores you know it's not something
that's over there and the other thing is
I think that we can everyone had a
verdict I think before the trial even
begun so everyone is just looking to
have their verdict backed up by the
evidence by by the witnesses by all of
that it's great water cooler talk you
know it's easier to talk about that and
you can relate because ultimately we can
put ourselves in that shoe what would
you have done if you had seen it we
can't really put ourselves in the shoes
of the Egyptians because we don't live
like that that's not our reality
well interesting i want to show just an
image of CNN what they've been doing uh
so they're showing Zimmerman all the
time and sometimes they're skyping
people in that box on the left and
they're showing the truck and Egypt is
getting a tiny unit right picture in
picture box uh live protests in Egypt
it's actually changed at some point
today it was watching now which is
bizarre because it's like the table
we're watching but you really should be
watching but we're not gonna have you
people watching it I mean ratings but
we'll want to see mm but do people do
that my question is this do people
really I think we just keep feeding them
crap and they just keep ingesting it do
they really want to see these trials do
you want to see these Charles really
want to see these trials but yeah I
found it all over the television last
night and since it's everywhere you get
sucked in and you start watching and you
would expect more from CNN sadly you
would Nancy Grace sure all day long
wall-to-wall but not CNN when so much is
happening in Egypt it would be different
if nothing was going on this week at all
but yeah I think since it's forced down
our throats then we go interesting well
maybe those lacerations aren't you know
conducive with you know being oh right
is there anything more irrelevant really
than hour after hour of trial coverage
again I'm not diminishing the importance
of the trial but but the minutiae of
what goes on in a trial and the
back-and-forth drivel and the
questioning and the and that we know
that most whatever gets decided he and
probably has nothing to do with the
truth that is only doing who manipulated
it better like can you think of anything
that would be more irrelevant for five
hours in a row to show that a trial what
would be more dribbling watching paint
dry I don't know yeah um and I think
like I said I I think part of it is
where it's driven down our throats I
think part of it is that's what we want
we are responding to them to these
stories by giving our ratings and tuning
in and that's the problem they wouldn't
be doing this there would be no supply
without demanding I mean it's a chicken
and egg situation zhang drama people
love drama i think if they're not so
proper taking so let's watch yeah right
well interestingly yesterday i was on
twitter goin crazy about this and I I
tweeted at CNN's Jake Tapper who was on
air at the time and I said Jake do you
on your own show that has your name on
it do you even decide what story was
first cuz they did literally 12 minutes
Zimmerman and then they did about a
minute on Egypt and he tweeted at me
during the commercial break and he said
it depends what's happening live which I
thought was bizarre because uh that's
there there a million people and Jack
like Jake but it was an odd response
anyway this whole Egypt thing is is
going to keep going for a long long time
and hopefully right now if you were to
turn on any other network they're doing
a better job and I hope that they will
continue